it's been a question about what the most
significant innovation or developments
will likely to be over the next decade
and I would hazard that there are two
areas that need this innovation more
than any other the first is energy we
aren't merely doing sufficient in
respect of clean sustainable forms of
energy you know they've been broad
discussions at Copenhagen unfortunately
insufficient to reach an agreement on
how to bring down the level of co2
emissions but it does lay the basis for
innovation in respective energy I think
they're still perceived risks around
nuclear and for some reason soul is not
quite there and for many countries that
have developed a dependence on coal wind
becomes a very expensive source of
energy so the big innovation salt in
clean energy at lower costs that focus
on costs and access to prove income in
the second has to be in respect of
health care ensuring the health care is
available that pharmaceuticals are
available to the court is so much more
spent on on drug treatments for wealthy
people for diseases in the wealthy and
yet diseases that impact on the poor
including HIV and AIDS malaria still
river blindness arising from black fly
I'm not being properly treated because
there's too little investment in
research and innovation for drug
vehicles in respect to finance clearly
it ought to be financed for development
finance for manufacturing finance for
change and not as we've seen over the
past 15 years or so a financial sector
that exists in own name and write these
are the big issues that will confront us
and as we deal with them I'm sure that
we will make significant improvements in
lifting more and more people from the
ravages of
No